hi i'm katie i'm a tasty producer and
today i'm going to be testing out some
of the most popular breakfast gadgets
we've got the hamilton beach dual
breakfast sandwich maker
then we've got the pancake bonanza and
last but not least we have
makin bacon let's go make a lot of
breakfast
right here we have the hamilton beach
dual sandwich maker
so right on top we've got instructions a
quick start that's probably what i'll
use
it's got a pretty finish on the top here
i think this is
nonstick the quality feels pretty nice
actually you know if someone came over
they'd be like that lady is serious
about her breakfast it just looks like a
torture device a little bit
can you see now is this better can you
see now
i love breakfast sandwiches i make them
all of the time
so i'm excited to try to make one in
these
so i have all my ingredients to make
some breakfast sandwiches what i found
is he doesn't have a very
long cord but fortunately i have a
massive uh huge extender cord
oh little beep okay oh and he's got a
little
numbers i think this is for your timing
yes i'm gonna open this guy up
use my mitt here now the quick start
directions say to put the base
on the bottom so i've got cheese i love
cheese i'm gonna do one
that's like fully loaded just like
intense and then i'm gonna just do
another one
that is a little bit more like basic now
i'm gonna put my
safety mitt back on i will say this is
like hot be careful
um okay next we're gonna crack eggs into
this slot here we go
let's just try it okay
it says in the instructions so poke the
yolk at the top and then i'm just gonna
try to
push this around so it's a little more
even oh
okay and i broke my yolk that's okay
second time's the charm
oh my gosh it's getting very hot i will
say
i'm gonna poke the yolk in this one we
put the tops
of the breakfast sandwich on top of that
don't burn yourself people okay
and then we're gonna close it like so
their recommended time four to five
minutes
[Music]
okay four minutes on the clock this is
when you can just like go
put four minutes worth of makeup on talk
to your children if you have them
help them put on their shoes
hey we got 37 seconds on the clock 36
it's counting down like a bomb five
four three two
one breakfast blast off
oh i thought it was a fun little song
but it's just
beeping rotate the cooking plates out
so okay it's a little bit strong okay
rotate it out we got a little bit of egg
residue we're rotating
this other one a lot of egg residue on
that guy
then it says to lift them all up with
oven mitts
don't forget all right so not like the
easiest
reveal turn off the heat the only way to
turn off the heat is to unplug it
oh very hot very hot i'm going to set
him over there to cool down
he worked a hard day's work
okay and here's our little breakfast
sammies it's a little bit
wet on the bottom but the rest of it's
very crispy okay here we go
that was really good actually the pepper
got cooked just enough you know where
it's not like too overcooked it still
has a little bit of a crunch
the egg is completely cooked through and
the ham is nice and hot i'd say
a minus and now let's try the more basic
one
okay so here we go that's totally hot
that's so good
this taste on the second one will give
like an a because there was no
sogginess it was nice and crisp nice and
toasty and the meat was heated all the
way through
i'm very impressed and surprised okay so
overall for the hamilton beach dual
sandwich maker it worked pretty well as
far as how things tasted
nothing was cold it was nice and crispy
i really enjoyed the flavor and you can
do so many different combinations and
customize that
i'd say that's awesome the two negatives
i would say is just that it's a little
bit clunky
it has a lot of moving parts i did try
to clean it
and this does pop out but it's just a
little bit hard to get in on all those
nicks and crannies so it's not super
simple or quick to clean
okay we're done with this and now it's
time to have a pancake bonanza
what does that mean does anyone know
what bonanza actually means
a situation or event that creates a
sudden increase in wealth good fortune
or profits
wait so if i make a bunch of pancakes
my wealth and profits is gonna change i
thought bananas was a party
okay it's kind of small but i guess i
mean we're not all making diner pancakes
that are huge this is a normal sized
pancake a nice soft grip on the handles
here
instructions just popped out it's copper
inside ladies and gentlemen copper which
conducts heat really well
flipping pancakes can be tricky you know
like have you ever had it like
you flip it and it like lands on the
side this hopefully
is going to get us like a nice pancake
on both sides perfect
and it's supposed to be nonstick
sometimes you have those pancakes that
you're like
scraping off the bottom so let's check
it out let's go
have a pancake bonanza and i'm gonna get
rich
this is hot now this is ready to go i'm
going to open them up pancakes are kind
of messy
i'm going to turn the heat now to low
yeah it's looking like
it's filled out nicely we're getting
bubbles it's starting to really cook
here
i'm going to close him up and we'll
check on him in just a minute the
problem
i'm finding now is you can only make one
pancake at a time it's also strange that
i can't look at the progress
of my pancake as that is so essential
for like knowing when to flip
i think you could flip moment of truth
ready
bam it's a little darker than i like my
pancake to be
this is also a little bit awkward to be
like hey you want a pancake like whoa
don't do that he looks nice it has a
good
shape i want to try another one with the
heat a little bit lower
all right nicely spreading out flip time
oh that is so satisfying that's the best
part about this
all right uh this guy ready to serve
again dangerous
why don't we try some with some
chocolate chips in it i'm just gonna
eyeball this
a little more better okay that looks
good
cooking pancakes and butter is always
delicious but you don't have to add
anything to keep it not sticking from
the pan
i like this my only issue with it right
now is that you just
you can't do that many and you're
waiting for a while
and chocolate chip pancake ready to come
off
okay so i'm just gonna add my favorite
toppings this pancake uh we're gonna add
a little butter
maple syrup i'm just gonna sprinkle a
few
chocolate chips
this guy's pretty fluffy right in here
he's just like nice and thick and we got
like oh
one of our chocolate chip bits right
there that looks
delicious i say this did a great job
they're consistently fluffy
they have a nice shape and they weren't
that hard to flip
so overall these tasted pretty good i'd
say like an
a minus b plus i mean it didn't change
the pancake flavor
but it kept them all nice and fluffy and
around the same size i don't know if
it's a thing you necessarily need unless
you really care about the look
of your pancake so i guess it just
depends if you're
a visual person then maybe this is the
thing for you
so we have the original macon bacon
microwave rack
i just want to talk about abby the
inventor she
looks like she's eight and she's from
the 90s
so it looks like you just put them on a
rack you put a paper towel over it
you microwave it and then you eat it
um okay what we've got here is like a
dustpan it looks like
so this thing holds the little rack in
place
and then you twist it
and then i think and then you can take
it out okay there's no instructions
so we're on our own did i lose the
instructions
oh oh on
the back you'll never lose the
instructions because it is a part
of the gadget microwave use only one
insert drip bars into the holes we did
that
great i'm gonna go get some bacon and
we're gonna test
we've got a bunch of bacon here we're
gonna go
with thick cut first i'll do four strips
on each drip rack
make sure you wash your hands ladies and
gentlemen okay
cute it's like hanging up your laundry
it's a fun activity
this is a nightmare what happens if
they're dangling too much should we
should we cut them this is not what abby
wanted oh my god okay
this is just horrifying but you're
getting a lot of strips done
you aren't gonna get a splatter of oil
so far it's
it's pretty gross but who knows what
it'll taste like i'm gonna cover
the paper towel and then it says
a minute per strip and i'm gonna do
eight minutes because that's how many
strips there are
right so we are less than one minute out
betsy
a fellow tasty producer has come by to
check this out
i mean when i walked in i was like she's
making bacon 100
great but was it smelling like good
bacon i mean it smells like microwave
bacon okay do you want to see who
invented it
this little girl named abby a little
girl invented
it kind of looks like you katie no was
it from the 90s or 80s it's the 90s okay
yeah here we go oh is it plastic yeah
it's plastic in the microwave
[Music]
oh my god oh my god that is terrifying
[Music]
that is wrong it doesn't really taste
like anything
i think we need to give abby another
chance and do it for a little less time
because maybe we just cooked it too long
let's give abby a second chance so we're
back
and we're gonna give this another try
i'm not gonna cut
the ends of this i'm just gonna let them
live their best life
okay making bacon take two four minutes
we're cutting the time in half
okay and they're definitely not
cooked enough two more minutes hopefully
this is the this is good and we do abby
proud
okay here we go
okay hey
the thick bacon is not quite finished
it's still a little undercooked
but the thin bacons they're looking done
much nicer than the last time
i'm gonna try one now
[Music]
it's just missing everything you love
about bacon it's so it's so dry
it's way too crispy it's just chalky so
i guess if you want something healthy
this is healthier but
it's still bacon so if you're gonna have
bacon i feel like just
enjoy it taste wise i am gonna give this
like
a c minus a d first time around we'll
give it an f it really was bad the first
time
this worked i don't know like it worked
well that it was it cooked the bacon
it took the fat off so if this is
something you're considering buying
maybe if you're gonna like put it in a
sandwich and like cover it with a bunch
of other
flavors and things but i would just say
if you're gonna have bacon it takes
about the same amount of time to cook
the bacon as it does in the pan
so i don't it's not saving you that much
time this i cleaned up
between bacons and it's super easy to
clean but otherwise
it's i just feel like go for real bacon
well thank you guys for watching us test
all of those crazy
breakfast gadgets um let us know your
thoughts in the comments do you own one
of these things
and also if you have any ideas for what
we could test next
make sure you leave them in the comments
section until next time
bye
[Music]
[Music]
you